hello welcome to this video this is
round eight of the sink filled cup
penultimate round so we're getting close
to the end of the event and aronian is
still leading the whole field especially
after Carson has lost this game in Ron
seven against greece shocked he looks
like very likely being the winner
however this round still has some
suspense round eight yeah I've cards and
manages to win he'll go get close to
aronian and there are still some others
in contention so let's start I'm going
to start with the game Wesley is sold
with white versus to par love to Paul
off let me note that game to pull off
had a great start with two wins but
after that really couldn't get anywhere
and lost a couple of carefully
frustrating games i believe yeah and so
really has a terrible event everything's
going wrong for him let's see what we
got here got a nympho indian with this
line the night ii to line yeah that's a
very safe line for white um i don't find
it particularly threatening i think
black basically equalizes um with their
almost anything in this case d5 was
played by two part of the system the
main move I've got this move in my my
book because I'm particularly fond of
this all the way we treat to have eight
and that leaves black rather flexible
about his pawn structure you can still
play D Phi if you can no you are very
flexible after d 5 which is the most
interesting move for white um we get
something a little bit more fighting d 5
is however the main move and one
drawback of it is that it is a bit less
interesting in my opinion in this case
um so went for c5 grabbing space and
then before yes this is a way to play it
with white white grep space on the
queenside and hopes to do something with
that
and this can easily be compared to a
line of the Queens gambit declined let's
do one thing I know it's canova yeah we
have currently this line is quite
popular now remember that white set up
right is called a bishop here a knight
on f3 Bishop on f4 night on a 3 so let's
now go to the game here here White has
an ID on YouTube which is totally
misplaced you will have to reroute it
and it's got the bishop on c1 and he
cannot easily deploy his bishop on the
positive side black has spent one move
two moves three moves with his bishop so
why does gain space against space yeah
he did that and time but the quality of
a speech placement isn't that great that
being said of course why it is totally
solid here we got some trades and this
again was traded 94 this is probably not
the most precise moves just Bishop e7
asst it's probably better but I actually
think the black position is is rather
solid he's got less space but we would
see that we basically got everything
traded down here and here the only thing
that black has to do is to stay alert
two white ones in a while threatening a
little something and if he does that
it's not going to lose the game I mean
of course black can never have a wind
but it's simply not much going on they
continued this here for quite a while
but there is simply nothing to do yeah
that's really no used to
again yeah we see that both sides they
had tons of time on the clock they could
really blitz that out yeah I mean really
how we'll see how are you ever going to
get anywhere or make a mistake you just
stay and and that's it yeah I mean a
couple of more moves and draw yep and
this is was just very very boring and
non-game in a way as I said the white
line there is solid and other thing but
to win a game with it is quite difficult
okay let's go to geary caruana the next
game to look at don't have in particular
what I'm just going to do the games that
are most relevant for the final
standings last um yeah we got a good
felt here and we have one of the the
main lines nowadays against the goon
fraud karana now comes up with an
interesting movie 5 this is a very
uncommon move um I have seen that idea
but so early on it is kind of kind of
unusual I found a couple of games in my
database so it's not a novelty but it's
really rare I don't think it's
particularly bad idea it seems
interesting Black is attacking the
center very very directly and my term
probably has to play as some giving our
plate plate Knight f3 I don't think that
D Phi for example Nets very much this
leads to a rather well-known structure
let's say after b6 wear black quite
often will play f5 to get some play yeah
white has a protected passer which is
something but it's not going to promote
any time sooner black has its play as
well um this is some the most normal
move I guess they also been games with
this but here black just usually getting
this back and
seems interesting okay now i have three
and now that was all traded down there
should be seven bishop out and
ninety-six oh thats that's all very
logical we see that black has traded the
whole center whiter ever still has that
pawn on e4 and maybe has a very slight
advantage because of that pawn it's
however really nothing special um if we
look what happened here it seems that
the the slight advantage that white
might had evaporated a little bit here
95 was an interesting opportunity that's
that has been suggested by Casper off he
was attending then broadcast in the
studio in st. Louis very interesting and
we I didn't watch it unfortunately I
register just using the codes that are
in this comment area by by a mr. Ramirez
um ya know g5 was Kasparov suggestion
and it seems indeed a little bit better
then what happened in the game best
seems to be Ruby 72 to cover that that
pawn and now something like Age 3 Bishop
back and now from here maybe white has
it or something a group d 1 it's it's
nothing spectacular but it is quite nice
there are some funny points there for
example here h6 you have this strong
move like ticks here we're taking here
and rook the eight is now quite nice for
wide white had some chances here but
book be one was a little bit a little
bit too meek probably we now had some
trades yeah and the next interesting
moment comes around here not be five was
probably a bit better staying near the
Queen side and the way it happened black
actually won that porn on a four
white cannot really keep that part and
he gave it up the thing is it is not
that terrible because this configuration
is not especially active and white gets
to join or and join us wrong again get
to go on the same rank with this rook
and this is a really really active white
always should have enough activity to
draw this now we can jump a little bit
forward while I was staying active
that's all totally normal and I joins in
black got this but white is Nyjah fries
yeah getting this one back and again we
have a situation where these are not
doing much and white is very active I
think with the precise play um the
likelihood of a draw is very very high
and we see after a couple of more moves
now this happen ninety five or six and
hear em GUI commits a mistake he had
lots of time on the clock so it's a bit
down a bit surprising Knight g4 was
still good just attacking in that rook
and stay active he played rooks III
however which is not really clear what
it is doing and after that koala as the
chance to do to go ruge f5 and now it
gets a bit awkward because that night
cannot move yeah why does already forced
to play this yeah there was some threat
of increasing that pressure on the night
so he has to cover it beforehand yeah
and here um kawana plate b6 after that
we pretty much by force Landon to the
end game that we were going to get with
some little twist but um the different
approach here was route 83 that was a
bit better but difficult difficult to
see this move was especially difficult
to see it's rather strange but has this
point
and in this end game the a pawn provides
winning chances for black it's might
still be a draw but it's a it's really
not it's not like that that strong
players even grandmasters can so quickly
assess if this is a draw win sometimes
people think that this is so easy this
is that this is not so clear I mean here
the rook is covering from the side which
is far better than having the rook on a
one let's say your chances of activating
the king of pretty um are there um I'm
not completely sure I think black has
really good practical winning chances it
might be a draw with perfect play but
something that Caruana certainly would
have preferred over the game as we will
see now you played the b6 move
immediately and white took it yeah check
check check and it looks bad but it's
not a big problem look everyone is what
give you played in fact he could have
played king f3 this looks very strange
but this is in fact really a draw if the
night is trapped in the corner it's
really funny black doesn't have more
than perpetual check check ya can check
check forever but at the end this is the
problem it cannot go anywhere so black
has to perpetual let what was all that
was a lot easier but give you played
king f1 I probably didn't see ruby file
this is somewhat computer ischium rook
takes g2 and this is what happened now
this thing and white draws this without
much effort um the thing is that maybe
Geary had seen this and I was thinking
okay I'm going to draw that easily and
it didn't look for something else that's
it's possible by the way I'm still
pretty amazed how some engines evaluate
this position I'm
stockfish on a decent computer decent
depth things that is minus 1.5 which is
a pure joke I mean this is it's really
just a draw and I mean I understand that
you don't probably want the engine to
show 000 as Black has practical and
chances in a game but 1.5 really yeah
this is kind of a joke because that 1.5
would mean to me like okay it's it's a
pawn maybe also like materially upon and
something else and this is really just a
draw so you cannot call it 1.5 but ok
the engines still have some some weird
spots here and there thankfully you can
still think for yourself and spot the
moments where the evaluation is nonsense
we will see something similar later so
next game we shook with white versus MBL
yeah do you remember that there was a
game Carl's and versus the French player
early on and it's the same line goo shop
tries exactly the same and now mdl
improves on his play it doesn't take on
c4 again it takes on d5 place Queen to
be 6 this was already suggested after
the the cards in game and it's
interesting that Kasparov who tended to
the broadcast said that he had prepared
this position for black for a match a
long time ago yeah it's a little bit
like a long time ago sounds a little bit
like the opening credit credit of Star
Wars yeah in a in a galaxy far far away
a long time ago or something like that
yeah what kind of match is that yeah
probably against scalp off in the night
from the early nineties late 80s a
couple was playing the fianchetto system
from time two top so maybe it was a
preparation versus scalp of possible
okay nite b3 and d6 yeah what to say
about this position we've got the open
sea
and why it has a space advantage with
that pawn on d5 on the other hand we
shouldn't forget that it also somewhat
blocks the bishop and blacks bishop is
pretty active yeah so blacks Bishop
seems a little bit more relevant in this
position however as I said why it has a
little bit more space and he also will
gain a little bit of time but we should
be three for example i think the
position is is roughly roughly equal
probably maybe i would prefer i
personally would prefer white a little
bit due to my liking or space but it is
not something very substantial Queen
sorry bishop d to hear no Knight a5 that
was Grecians idea placing that night
actively not sure how much this net some
in the in the game here it seems that
after this continuation the only thing
that white has is this night outpost on
c6 this is probably the idea behind 9
a-5 if you wanted to get that pawn and
then put the knight on c6 we see that
this of course this happened some
somewhat later here here 96 is in the
position but the question is how much is
it is that really affecting the whole
thing e 7 is very securely protected by
the bishop on f6 and just sayin same
problem that's not much whenever white
goes into c6 he also neglect said square
so that sometimes Bishop c4 is an option
here we have some trades now Bishop here
and I think it's basically nothing it's
not much to play for now we have to oops
I'm sorry I pushed the wrong button
there yeah we have to be aware that
white cannot tgim because of the back
rank can't be really unfortunate and
also later here here again he can try
that but it's not bleeding anywhere yeah
like it's far too active something
this where is this route going going
here not good going here yeah it's it's
not helping we should just basically
stayed here didn't do much we had a
couple of move repetitions and now a
draw agreed yeah that was a bit a bit
too tame probably to get to get anywhere
and ultimately and not very exciting
exciting draw okay let's go to aronian
are not our tournament leader levon
aronian with us former champion vcr not
yeah aland not having a good avandia
really not but tries to hang in there
yeah we have an english opening again I
wrong yet going for c4 he did that
earlier in the event with white versus
Carlton mixing up c4 n't for nowadays
quite a bit um and term here we have
Bishop b4 which is playing online sees
players playing d5 Bishop c5 and Bishop
before even 94 has tried to all of them
Bishop before has a very solid
reputation it is quite comparable to the
Russell emo variation in the Sicilian
defense with three Bishop b5 one
difference here however is that black
always has this knight on c6 which is
difference to the Russell Nemo where
white is often flexible with the sea
pornic and often place is 6 this makes
the white reply 95 at some point of
interesting here for example aronian
played Bishop g2 but 95 is also very
common common reply to that which is not
so much a problem in there also Li mo SS
and there is no knight on c3 um Bishop
g2 was played all that looks very normal
and now again black has some choice you
can go rook e8 various things you played
efore this is the most direct play
g5 and now black has to give up his
Bishop down c three leah takes takes
rook e8 yeah here um White has a very
fundamental choice he needs to do
something about this pawn and this night
on g5 if Black gets to play let's say
age six and we have to go back to age
three this is not that brilliant I mean
it's not terrible but you don't really
want the night to go to the edge of the
board that easily and you want to do
something about this pawn the main moves
here f3 and d3 you three is though this
may be the I don't know 2k no more
conservative yeah I'm own ian had played
this also in game sir notably one game i
think against boris gelfand um but f3
now's plane it's a bit a bit sharp at
this move here there's a legendary game
you could spar off with white was a
scalpel from the 1987 World Championship
match of a cup of played the movie 3m
and really surprised this part of one of
the rare cases where Karpov Kalinda
really an yeah tough novelty to face for
Kasparov and a cup of later won that
game but this is the main move takes d5
deform and I mentioning lots of kasparov
because he was in the studio so he had
details he form this is a move that was
played by wassily even shock in a 1988
game against Gaspar oh no I don't think
a Casper eventually actually played 94
hey I'm sorry that was Quincy two tix
rupee one f5 and now the movie for a
very dynamic play by by Kasparov and if
one should got crushed really really
quickly here the capture was played
Bishop g5 looks dangerous and with them
pinned there on that night takes takes
takes and here first instinct is a 95 is
strong and it is not that clear whatever
95 Queenie 6 and now why it doesn't have
anything particularly great
for example if he if he grabs here and
now takes on f7 oops I'm sorry on f7
then Queen III is actually winning from
black yeah we see that after something
like this this bishop well no it should
be seven it's going to hit and why this
and in total difficulties will lose the
game quickly 95 here takes takes rook
takes is also possible but again let's
see five a very strange position but we
shouldn't forget that white has this
weakness where this King something like
a bishop to be seven and queen 35 will
be very very awkward to meet and white
also has kind of very very shaky piece
configuration here so this is probably
not that great yeah I only underwent
before that was all part of preparation
here Bishop g4 developing yeah of course
taking now was really impossible due to
this the end multiple the text there
Bishop g4 Queen a 426 and now look a to
e 1 was played by Aronian may be slow
part of the preparation and 24 was maybe
slightly better the ideas that rupee for
its not working due to 95 um when White
has to take that pawn there anyway and
probably you don't have to commit your
work on you 1 through P 8 and b5 that
was also one thing that could have been
avoided by the immediate Queen see for
now Black gets counter play with that
porn yeah II five now interesting it
could have moved the queen of course but
black always has gone to play this is
something very very obvious let's say if
the sea pawn moves then white
it's going to lose that part so black
hands pressure on that on that Center if
I've is probably the better choice but
now after this we get a position upon
down check yeah widest really upon down
but he's got activity you know attacking
this attacking this this is a good move
it looks a bit strange the edge of the
board and everything but ultimately
black has got a rather solid defensive
set up that night is strange but it can
return and black is protecting his
weakness there auntie 5y cannot enter on
the Sabbath because of that night now a
couple of moves later we got here and
now 9 a-6 yeah black played room 27 here
preventing any 97 ideas and now a form
king of aid and you see I already have a
suspicion there yeah they repeated for a
draw and a case where and both sides
really couldn't continue it wasn't it
wasn't really possible around here I
mean here black has to play Rupert e7 to
keep d5 protected 95 I mean white cannot
really play for win if blankets given
time he just will maybe use his King in
the defense so you have to do this
basically and well Roxy 7 is the case of
what else do you really play here and
give white this opportunity there's no
need yeah I mean black is not playing
for win with this is rather trying to
try to do some kind of stuntman routine
yeah can I survive this am and this is
really not a good attitude if you really
have the choice between just drawing
with the repetition and continuing in a
position where you feel that you're not
having any clear idea how to win then
you should really just take the draw I
mean continuing just for the sake of not
drawing it's quite often a bad idea
sometimes the position is just what it
is and it has to be drawn here that
happened ok let's look at cards Nakamura
then a modern classic the two
two rivals they're currently Nakamura is
some you see number two I mean with the
live ratings that changing daily um I
think you might be right he's probably
number two at the moment so Carson has
wide got a default opening and again we
will see Carlton getting pressure yeah I
mean I think he's really good getting
better positions with not one year for
but anyway just my take on it yeah a
couple of plays Bishop e7 um he's
playing the Queens gambit declined this
is Anna cameras super solid option
against e4 and I mean he's got many
sharp openings in his repertoire the
Kings Indian wind only sometimes the
Dutch and this is his solid solid option
they probably would have played
something like the child a coma or the
last confirm it would if from the cards
Malik Knight f3 Bishop g5 he played
Bishop f4 however that's an interesting
move that's not seen so often it's um
obviously very much related to this but
why does delaying the night f3 move it's
an interesting interesting choice also
interesting that Nakamura still went for
Bishop e7 even though nowadays Knight f6
the the classic remove has gotten back
into fashion as the exchange variation
with C takes it takes has lost some of
its sting youtube those some ideas here
with night h5 with age six inserted or
not at Sam both has been tried
successfully silly plays Bishop e7
Bishop f4 and then III castles a3 an
interesting move water really
interesting what is the point yeah one
point is that the most reliable way
nowadays to play against the night f3
included line I mean just imagine the
night being here instead of a 3 being
played in that position with the knight
on f3 knight BD 7s the main move which
here can be answered with 95 that's a
difference in the other position black
hands bishop before check which makes be
sure not be five completely ridiculous
the point of this move is that c6 is
take due to Bishop c7 queen here 96 flag
losses kind of embarrassing a way to
play so black has to play 98 and now
after for example let me have a look
there there was a game just want to be
precise Knight f3 c6 back and f5 this
was played in a game galfond with white
against aronian yeah so this must play
this process as possible like it's not
terribly off here transposing into a
stone wall where this is really having
some significance the night can
sometimes go here as a ronnian plate he
tried to really prove that it wasn't
just some kind of time loss and putting
the night only eight so black can play
nine bd7 here but ok he has other
options one option that was mentioned by
Casper office b6 which caused power of
claim to be best an interesting
statement the relationship through the
night air 3b6 line is rather clear here
a 3 in a b6 structure looks relatively
useless it is never completely useless
because Bishop before for example is an
idea now for example let's just say
white would trade I'm just putting out
some moves and now you play this for
example and without a three that's
obviously this check as for a three is
kind of useful but I understand
kasparov's rationale there that b6 is
probably a good idea it's a more
powerful for sure than with Knight f3
but nakamura played c5 yeah this is now
transposing to the old main line of the
Bishop f4 system yeah this is now a day
this is normally reached if we go from
here this is normally reached via this
water this this is the same position as
in the game and nowadays this has been
less unpopular for black quite clearly
because it's believed that white has a
slight advantage and this is
exactly what happened in the game is so
somehow Carla's move autumn brought
Nakamura to UM to play to play like this
Queen a five-year ruki aid was tried by
cards in there with black in the world
championship match but ok we get to that
rook to e1 position and here it seems
that black has some problems he
completely equalizing he doesn't have a
clear way to do it and this was played
by a Nakamura before as a threat so
Bishop e7 makes sense we should be tuned
and now maybe the best online is to take
on c4 Bishop takes Knight age five
castles and this this was painting a
game kramnik with white against cards
and I Carlton has some experience of on
the black side from 2009 back then in
2009 it wasn't so clear that night BTW
seven on move six seems to be the better
defense this is around that time it
became clear that this probably is it's
the better choice for black but this M
is a bit better than white but but still
very very solid chrome naquan a nice
game there by the way in 2009 against
Carlton ok Bishop e2 94 was Plato over
here bye bye Nakamura and this some
continued that's a pretty frosting
sequence the strainer 94 and interesting
is that Kasparov mentioned that this
this line was part of his work with cars
in a few years back and they had
concluded that white is somewhat better
then I have to agree with that yeah what
is somewhat better due to the better
activity what pieces are more active
Luke on d5 904 and one important thing
is why it has not cancelled yet this
means that in many cases the King can
play useful role in the center
King mo NGA it's not really helping a
lot in the proceedings an interesting
question is how to defend their now for
black the cameras choice it wants to
check on d4 and I don't know I mean I
know that the engines don't like it and
the thing is the alternative that the
computers give I also don't like so I'm
not quite sure really about this
position um a5 is what the engines give
and I mean I understand this is the the
passer you want to push your pawn and so
on all nice but it's still not clear to
me that this leads to anything
substantial because well All Whites
pieces participate the king is on
probably Kingda to now the king is
helping and sometimes what the engines
do they evaluate that passer and then
push it and deep down the road it gets
picked up by White's pieces but the
engines don't see that and because it's
too deep and this could be one of those
cases and the thing is that the a porn
is really on its own yeah black is not
ever getting be five in now and I'm not
sure about this I think white is still
better I mean ok the if you give it is
to stop fridge or some some some top
engine it gives right a slight advantage
but 0.2 or whatever it silly eights but
I mean why it is definitely more
comfortable yeah so the opening result
was really excellent for Carlton and in
any case and after this after the
capture I think why this is really
substantially better be six King need to
Bishop e6 a funky line is this text the
bishop and if it takes this is trapped
quite funny don't have that you're often
abuse in this look is doing a good job
yeah but should be six rupee five here
here who should bear three yeah I mean
some people might say oh wait doesn't
have black outside passer
on the a file isn't that good for him
the thing is no All Whites pieces put
pressure all of them yeah really
Bishop's the roofs those pawns are also
worth something and the king is helping
and this position is it's close to close
to being lost for black I belief really
it's it's really really bad and we'll
see in the game that Carlton progress is
very nicely b5 Bishop to c6 know keeping
that on the board yeah and black has to
do something the apron was hanging and
we see the big pressure now I had the
beep on and this is a somewhat
unfortunate situation from black you can
never play the B Paul and it's it's it's
in general unclear what what you're
doing really rupee 8d 58 and King be
three yeah this is kinky threesome as a
move that keeps everything under control
and basically states I have all the time
in the world that is true however I
didn't really see a big issue why not
play this and just pick up material I
mean why not Black has to play we could
be c 8 I mean we are threatening to take
here and then click here and not s are
you create is covering there but I mean
it's the exchange yes to use the rook
and now we should be six and I don't see
how um I don't see how black show
defenders it just totally lost your
winning the a pond and there are no
tactics like checks here or something I
mean it's a total win so it's a bit
mysterious why this wasn't playing I
mean I understand that this does win as
well I mean it's not giving away
something but just taking the material
was probably easy
aight bishop deform f6 yeah kini volume
on all the time set C for that was the
idea should be for and now he went
Bishop a seven I mean okay um it's quite
quite mysterious to me I me now I always
look at the notes by alejandro ramirez
as i already stated a couple of times to
get the one side information for those
who haven't watched the broadcast like
like I am like like me um and he gave g4
as a better move and so on Bishop e7
wasn't a good idea about g4 is the
Calico that prevents everything at any
f5 check or whatever and just keeps
everything under control it's a good
move and will win but I don't see why
this is a mistake really it wins pretty
easily so why not this should 87 chat
five chick yeah going back now if white
takes only could have done so ok let's
go air-to-air three that that's a safe
move rugby c8 yeah and now we get CB
Bishop takes this was the point here and
bishops III that was the point here and
it's seemed I mean Ramirez basically
says that white could have prepared that
better yeah with g4 and so on um anyway
let's just look at this got this and now
move 39 yeah this is the the key
position of that game the total key
position and a really mysterious one as
the move played by cards is really
really bad I mean really bad I don't
really understand what was going on
there because I mean it's hard to tell
what you would look this is the problem
this is all I'm saying yet tons of time
and he played Bishop e3 relatively
quickly as we
um I really don't understand what
happened here I mean clearly overlooked
rook be eight I mean hard too hard to
believe um the thing is let's look at
the move I mean this is bad because
rupee eight now forces the trade of
rooks Bishop c4 is the only move takes
fatigues and now we got this end game um
okay I mean it's for a good player it's
very obvious that mean white has the two
bishops he has chances but to win it it
looks very very difficult to win I mean
very very very difficult if not maybe
it's also just the draw we look at it I
think it's just a row actually but I
mean if you just think about the thought
process you see that the airport is kind
of dangerous and the best that you can
do is maybe you can win the a pawn and
even then it's not so clear if you will
win the game so let's go back this is
what what happened no the alternative
was to not allow the rook trade which
could have been accomplished by a means
of the move Bishop f4 now that blocks
the pond and what wide is now doing he
just wants to reorganize themselves a
little bit you trying to get the look
here Bishop back and ultimately pick up
that part you will pick up that part it
will just take a little while and then
you will get threats with the two
bishops and the rook against the black
king I imagine the look on the seventh
maybe a bishop coming on the long
diagonal later I know currently it is
controlled with that this is the idea
the thing is that the two bishops and
the rook together stop that pawn very
easily but you need your rook as an
attacking unit to attack the g7 car to
attack the black king with with with two
bishops and rook against two ropes this
is really simple win I mean really
simple and I don't I don't understand
what happened here and nobody did really
want to having cars really it's not in
one hundred percent shape not for for
whatever reason but this is a very
strange that that
would allow this yeah now can we got
that end game and as I already mentioned
I actually believe it's a draw I ok i no
give it to an engine it gives one point
something and so on but the engine later
gives even more ridiculous stuff um I
think it's a draw because the best that
white can can achieve is getting the a
pond and we can go ahead a little bit
you know we can go ahead a little bit
and in fact cousin managed to get that
porn ok this is important movement
there's an important word here black
knocking Lewis F for that's a very nice
way to to defend this position very nice
tactic if white takes with the pawn then
black gets the H pot and no this is
actually getting tricky I mean black has
I mean White's not going to lose this
but hmm he's trying yeah not a good idea
to give black the h-bond so Bishop had
to take now a to Bishop takes Chang Qing
up and this so black managed with this
tactical operation to trade of the
airports and I think this is really what
is some is happening after the root tray
this is the best probably that white can
get out of this yeah winning the a porn
and maybe accepting that f portrayed him
and the thing is this is an again a
funny incident of the engine totally not
getting what's going on because stock
fishin gives to point something here to
point if your depends a bit on the
version I tried selfish five and six
stockfish six is a little bit better it
just gives 1.9 or 1.8 which is also
ridiculous because it's just a draw it
really is just the draw and it's
something that human player can
relatively easily see because what what
is the best that white can do here I
mean on a very good day you can get your
king king up here somewhere and maybe a
tech g6 together with admission but
black can always defend that that porn
from the side and white has very little
in terms of ideas
you can go g5 TX h 5 those kind of ideas
but it's also not going to happen yeah
we can continue a little bit the white
kicking god got somewhat nearer check
yeah and now black is keeping the rook
active and again as stock fish is still
on two points something I mean stockfish
5 and dimensions is what i have in them
in the desert sonogram just doesn't get
it let's say yeah yeah cousin try for
quite a while horse and because you can
not hello do so might as well try and
it's not much fun for black yeah but
just have to make sure I not blonde that
stuff check check check and we getting
close to the final stage of this king a
five year and now we're getting to
something that is really quite obviously
drawn yeah no cameras went with up to g4
and now he could sacrifices and there's
no way of keeping that porn so this was
the end of the game so a very
disappointing result for Carlton who had
a quite clear win with that Bishop a4
move and also clear wins earlier we have
Bishop a7 earlier also I've one material
so he's kind of out of shape here in
that event I mean as he already was in
the in the Norway chance he had some
good games yeah also I mean he did when
he won good games against West Des so
and against MBL but all in all it's a
bit too inconsistent especially am he's
normally really exceptionally good at
winning technically good positions I
mean even slightly better positions and
this was a total technical win and he
somehow didn't yeah I don't know usually
overlooked the move rupee aid or
whatever it was just a complete lapse of
mind um he really shouldn't allow that
pretty easy win and something that I
think under normal shape let's say if
you give to give that position to him
with like 10 minutes on the clock
against two hours he would probably win
that very easily but somehow this time
it's not working out so we have five
draws in that penultimate round which
make some proposition clear for the
final round aronian is leading by a full
point so has excellent chances of
winning the event unfortunately I forgot
who is playing in the last round he's
got black this is what i remember i
really did I really alone mm would have
to look it up alright so now I looked it
up the final round has a wrong young
playing black against Apollo okay the
power of not being very inspired the
last couple of rounds after his two
losses Carrie I'm guessing a drone was
very lucky carlin playing black against
Arnold we shook playing black against
Nakamura and the airplane widens Geary
yeah so yeah give really are they both
output plus one we have a couple of
players on plasma on geary mvl Carl's an
angry shock and Aronian on plus free
yeah most likely Aronian will draw
against Apollo with black and the other
games yeah what we will not see but his
looks looks very likely that they won't
win his first tournament for ages yeah
very deservedly so it was by far the
most stable player in that event okay
well thanks for watching